Yeah.
Well one of the things I
really can't figure out,
maybe you could shed
some light on this too,
is you know,
of all the things that women's political
movements should be doing in the West
is demanding.
As far as I can tell that
the western countries,
let's say led by their male rulers,
stop treating the Saudis like are there
are allies and I cannot understand why
there hasn't been concerted pressure put
on Western governments by women who are
concerned,
at least in principle with the equality
and freedom of women around the world to
stop treating the Saudis
like they're our allies.
And so that and that,
that's another thing that
perplexes me entirely.
And though cynical part of me thinks
that the feminists who are more or less
hell bent on the destruction of the
western Patriarchy adopt the attitude that
the enemy of my enemy is my friend.
And so they're willing to put
up with what the Saudis to do.
But I don't think that's
a sufficient explanation.
So like,
I mean you can view our,
our culture,
so to speak a little bit from,
from the outside position because you
have moved in as an immigrant and that
gives you a viewpoint that it's much
more difficult for someone within it to
share.
And so like what do you see as,
as driving the absence of pressure,
let's say from women on governments
in relationship to these?
I would say reprehensible dictatorships.
What's going on?
So the,
I mean she's cool.
I'll be occupied with Western
country after with the [inaudible].
What I see is that they have,
first of all,
that's all that they're focused on.
They do not talk about,
discuss Craig,
she's the issue or a men of color
and the Patriarchy of man of color or
immigrants or the nations and countries.
Men in nations and countries outside.
Right?
Oh,
the wench number feminists have also
written to the identity politics there for
to come to multiculturalism and
all these things are bad for women,
bad turn Western women and bad.
So if you believe multiculturalism
courses that before and that one person,
that's one project,
the wife had nothing to say
about the culture of Islam
since it's all sort of equal,
then they feel that they count,
um,
pressure
to address
list that black women and
Muslim women and women of color,
if they wanted to get out of oppression,
then they should organize themselves.
That's what they believe.
What I find ironic draw is that
sometimes when we do organize ourselves,
I am organized with all the extra Muslim
woman to talk about the misogyny that's
subjected to women in the name.
I get it from white linens,
white feminist,
atheist,
biggest puzzle ever.
The treatment that you've received
at the hand of Western feminists.
To me,
that's,
that's something that's just absolutely
leaves me absolutely speechless because
not only me,
it's all of us who are hiring.
Uh,
again,
like I thought only two ex Muslims,
but there are black women who are
fighting for their rights and they all get
shut down.